[Music]  Savior Monster Guardian vigilante the  preservation of life so often the  justification for taking it  humans elevating those that keep guard  until they watch too close and the  so-called hero condoning the very act he  would condemn transgressions of the past  shape actions to come  as offspring turns into adversary  yesterday's loss  beats to madness  and God becomes tyrant becomes outcast  becomes dust as factions dissolve and  for  and lust for power in slaves all  such folly and futility in the brand  design  curious how lines once clearly defined  become blurred  perhaps it is time for them to be  redrawn